nicole it's lovely to see you here today
I really enjoyed an F said
congratulations on making a wonderful
film let's talk a little bit about the
casting James Gandolfini and Julia
louis-dreyfus as well wonderful cast how
did they come on board they came on
board in a pretty traditional way I
didn't know either of them I had met
James a few years before and we really
hit it off and I imagined we would have
a really good time doing this and I
thought he'd be great for the part and
kind of similar Julie I'd watched her on
Seinfeld for a hundred years and was
intimidated to meet her but as soon as I
did we hit it off right away she was so
not the characters that she's played I
mean clearly that's a part of her but I
just I felt she would be a wonderful
very sympathetic Eva I heard that James
was a little bit unsure about doing
comedy tell me about a burnt um I'm not
sure he was unsure about doing comedy he
definitely has a sense of humor but his
it's very different from Julia I think
any human being would be intimidated by
Julia's comedic abilities and I did I
think he did feel like he had to keep up
with her um and as soon as he didn't as
soon as he did his own brand of comedy
it worked perfectly and tons of lines
that he's added and have stayed in the
movie he was unsure about playing I
think a leading man the leading romantic
interest was very far into him and he
kept looking at me like yeah sure about
this are you looking at the monitor and
I'd say yeah yeah I'm really happy this
is exactly what I want they work
perfectly together yeah I mean obviously
very sadly we've lost James Gandolfini
since since you made the movie and what
were your fondest memories when you look
back at that time that you spent
together with him and Julia together on
sent that shooting period hmm I guess
just we had a lot of downtime when we
were shooting in what was his house and
I remember sitting on that couch and
having a lot of laughs and he could be
kind of clownish and goofy and so can
Julia for sure both of them kind of
would do anything for a laugh and I
guess
I guess the laughs I don't know if
there's any one specific moment but um
sad yes absolutely i mean it but such a
marvelous film to have made him as well
and for you to work with him on this too
in this many many wonderful moments in
the film and we begin with Julia with a
lovely montage of these kind of terrible
moments that she experiences almost
something she complaining about the
writer job and buy her job as immerses
yeah and which made me kind of went to
what the best and worst things you think
about being a writer and director oh
well I don't have to touch any strange
naked body so that's net loss yeah um
well the best about being a writer is
probably the same thing that's the worst
it's isolating i mean i can i can write
a script in my bed in my pajamas and my
cat is there my dog is there my coffees
there and this is i'm getting paid for
this that's fantastic and at the same
time if i feel like i have no talent and
i can't think of anything to say and I
hate what I've written the day before
I'm alone in my house and then I just
fall asleep is that the question I guess
that's good that I can fall asleep yeah
but definitely we can relax and then
come back the next day refresh okay well
it yeah not fall asleep into like a sea
of self-loathing and then wake up
knowing that I have to write again okay
oh no yeah yeah let's go for the former
show ok I think that's let's stick with
it definitely now I am obviously I said
we see these not so great moments where
at the star of the film and I heard that
you had an interesting experience as a
director when you could you up to you
work on TV as well as yeah your own
movies yeah when you were directing a TV
show called Gilmore Gilmore Girls when
George Lucas came on sense um what
happened then tell me um well his
daughter apparently was a fan of the
show and so he came as a guest and was
standing at the monitor with his
daughter watching a shot that I'd set up
and it was actually not a well-set-up
shot to begin with which happens
occasionally and as I was setting it up
or as we're about to she was like you
know
it's not really the best angle for what
I'm trying to do and he and of course
the whole crew was listening to every
word he said and following him around
like Jesus and there were about 20
people standing behind me and him when
he said why why would you set it up like
that and he probably didn't even mean to
be mean i don't know maybe he was just
trying to chat but it was mortifying oh
I can imagine that's just how I killed
myself but we're glad you did it a video
here and there you made it up said that
would be terrible no goodness thank
goodness not they talked about in the
film about what sign they put themselves
you know for their bad habits well sign
would you put on yourself and what do
you think of your deal-breakers either
it were in relationship well I don't
really have deal-breakers I guess if
somebody is psychotic I would try not to
date them actually um I my sign would
say that I'm a judgmental and critical
and I'm working on that and that I blow
my nose and freak and then leave the
tissue somewhere that's not pretty hey
there's actually a whole thing in the
script but it got taken out I really
shot it yeah Julia's character says she
does that okay well what was stayed in
the script was great we really enjoyed
the film thanks good thank you so much
you